have you ever looked at your new home
and wondered why it costs so much or
maybe you've started a home improvement
project and the costs just keep going up
today we're breaking down six ways your
Builder might be cutting Corners
switching products and making Shady back
alley deals to fill their pockets and
empty yours for the past decade I've
practiced as an architect right here in
Western Australia and I've seen The Good
The Bad and of course the ugly there are
many excellent building out there ones
that truly want to do the right thing
for the entire industry and build the
best quality homes possible however
there are also a few Snakes in the Grass
these snakes are the ones you need to
watch out for and today we are focusing
on just that the snakes stick around to
the end of the video where I'll share
one simple trick to get your project on
track from day one now let's begin with
the hidden costs to be fair there are
hidden costs that are beyond the
Builder's control and therefore
considered legitimate underground
utilities or even ancient artifacts God
forbid they find human remains these
discoveries can significantly impact the
Project's timeline and costs even if
soil testing was completed early on
until the dirt is completely turned over
the challenges are completely unforeseen
knocking down old structures can also
uncover hidden structural issues espes
this or other hazardous materials
finally you might actually be the
problem and the one that increases the
budget you may decide to make changes to
the original design during the
construction process which these changes
regardless of their benefit to the end
result will result in additional costs
Builders like sticking to the plan and
any interruptions cause major ripples in
the project at the same time there are
hidden costs that are a result of poor
planning or unethical Behavior by the
builders if the Builder underestimated
the cost of your project and the actual
actual costs exceeds the fixed price
they may try to pass on additional
expenses to you often your contract
won't allow these costs to be passed on
hence why so many Builders went bankrupt
during the pandemic if the Builder fails
to properly plan the project it can lead
to delays and schedule overruns these
delays can result in additional costs to
the Builder which some Builders have
tried to pass on through inflated
variations a simple change of cladding
style or painting color could cost you
two to three times more than it really
should because the Builder is trying to
recoup some of that lost income now
weather also plays a very big role in
construction timelines and costs extreme
weather conditions can undoubtedly
interrupt the Project's process however
if the Builder claims weather delays
without proper documentation or seeks
compensation for additional costs
without justification it could be a sign
of dishonesty all of these factors can
be avoided and I'll tell you exactly how
in just a moment but first we need to
move on change orders are a common
occurrence in construction projects
these are modifications to the original
project scope are agreed upon between
you and the Builder while some change
orders are unavoidable due to unforeseen
circumstances others may be initiated by
the Builder for their own benefit common
tactics employed by some Builders is to
swap out specific materials or products
for Alternatives often without
consulting you the homeowner first at
all this works the best for products
that never see the light of day this can
be done for various reasons some
products may have extended lead times
causing delays if the original choice is
not available however when things go out
of stock unexpectedly then there is
Merit here of course what actually
happens though is Builders prioritize
products or materials that provide them
with higher profit margins make sure you
consult with your architect before
accepting this change order like I said
at the start of the video there are so
many good Builders out there with pure
intentions these Builders more times
than not pass on great savings or
excellent products which benefit both
you and them so it's a win-win the Shady
Builders they will convince you to
switch to an alternative that is cheaper
for them but equal or more for you
speaking of worse inferior materials are
a great way Builders can save on your
job one of the most common tactics
employed by unethical Builders is to
swap out specified products for cheaper
alternatives without your knowledge or
consent this deceptive practice can
occur in various ways for instance
swapping Out high-grade Steel
reinforcement for lower grade steel
reducing the thickness of concrete slabs
or even using substandard Timber May
compromise the whole structural
Integrity of the home replacing high
performance insulation with lower grade
materials may result in reduced Energy
Efficiency and high utility bills whilst
switching from quality tile suppliers to
a less rep one may result in a tile that
is more prone to cracking chipping or
fading and opting for cheaper glass that
does not meet requirements safety
standards or otherwise is just purely a
hazard making it difficult for you to
detect the substitution to be completely
honest it's hard for trained
professionals like myself to detect some
substitutions as it isn't feasible to
cross check every bit of Steel measure
every concrete slab and ring every
supplier to ensure that orders have been
fulfilled nonetheless you can limit your
exposure to risk by clearly defining the
specific products and materials you want
in the contract including brand names
models numbers and performance
specifications arrange for regular
inspections by qualified professionals
to ensure that the materials used comply
with a specific standards because what
you don't realize is the cost of an
engineer to inspect your job during
critical stages will be cents on the
dollar if major structural Corners are
cut but honestly the best way to avoid
inferior materials is by choosing a
buildup with a proven track record ask
for references before engaging them
speak to locals in the area and past
clients how that Builder's last five
jobs went is a great indication of how
yours might actually go poor workmanship
is another common problem with Builders
this can lead to a variety of problems
such as leaks draft and poor insulation
quality I won't spend too long on this
section because poor workmanship is
obvious to anyone in short your Builder
is fully insured repairs any defects for
at least the first 12 months warrants
all structural items based on your
country's laws and has a great
reputation in the industry if they're
just starting out ask other trades and
Builders who they might have worked with
in the past to get an indication of
their character by doing all this you'll
minimize your risk as much as possible
Kickbacks are a form of bribery they're
intended to gain an unfair advantage in
the marketplace Builders may receive
kickbacks from contractors or suppliers
in exchange for recommending or using
their products or Services even if
they're not the best option for your
project but don't be fooled this doesn't
just happen to builders many Shady
Architects fall victim to this same
bribery and you need to be always
questioning why selections are being
made if it isn't the best product for
your project there might be a hidden
reason for it but we're talking about
Shady builders in this video subscribe
for shady architects in the future
Builders you see May prioritize products
that offer Kickbacks regardless of their
quality or suitability for your project
this can lead to the use of inferior
materials that compromise the Integrity
of your home these hidden Kickbacks can
drive up the overall cost of your
project and as the builders may include
the kickback amount in their pricing
they're not actually passing on any
savings to you the best way to check if
the wo has been pulled over your eyes is
to compare the prices of recommended
products with similar options from other
suppliers or even by going to the supply
direct for a quote if the price are
similar chances are your Builder is
doing the right thing hiring a
professional can be the best decision
you make when embarking on a
construction project professionals such
as Architects designers project managers
bring expertise and experience they also
bring objectivity to the process helping
you navigate the complexities of
building and protecting your interest
your architect may not need to be there
every step of the way one or two site
visards could be enough to help you get
back on track now since you've made it
this far in the video I'd assume you're
ready to embark on your architectural
Journey which all begins with a
well-crafted project brief having spent
over a decade in the world of
architecture I've witnessed the powers
of clear concise briefs without one
projects can lose direction and end up
costing so much more than they should
have that's why I've introduced the DIY
architectural brief a user-friendly
template designed for you to
effortlessly Define your Vision to your
architect yes even if that's not me and
after which they can transpire your
vision to the builders this brief will
not only guide your project but will
also set it apart from anything making
it truly exceptional now for disclosure
this template isn't cheap it has taken
me years of my time to craft and
countless projects to test it on it's
not cheap because it requires your full
attention dedication and time to get it
right it should only be purchased by
those serious about their architectural
Journey otherwise you're wasting your
money no matter what it costs check the
link in the description down below and
grab your template today now if you want
to do the right thing then pay attention
building a home is a significant
undertaking and it's crucial to gather
information and seek guidance before
making any decisions one of the best
ways you can gain insights into the
construction process and the reputation
of builders in your area is to seek
advice from your locals and are ask for
references start by talking to your
neighbors your friends or your family
members who have recently built or
renovated their home they can provide
valuable firsthand experiences about the
builders that they've worked with
sharing their insights into the quality
of work communication and overall
satisfaction joining local online forums
or Community groups related to
construction or home ownership can
provide a wealth of information and
recommendations these platforms often
have discussions and reviews of local
Builders offering a wide range of
perspectives but please try to avoid the
negative groups where people just rant
about nothing these don't provide any
value and just impact your mental health
for no good reason real estate agents
Architects interior designers often have
extensive networks of builders in the
area as well they can provide
recommendations based on their
professional experience and knowledge of
the Builder's track record and of course
the Builder's reputation when seeking
advice ask specific questions about the
builders's work their ethics their
communication skills their problem
solving abilities and their adherence to
timelines and budgets inquire about
specific projects that have completed
and gather feedback from our home owners
involved gather information from various
sources and compare the recommendations
you receive pay attention to the common
themes and recurring feedback
considering the project scope complexity
and your specific needs when evaluating
the suitability of pedrol Builders last
contact the references and ask detailed
questions about their experience
including any challenges or issues that
arose during the project anyway that's
all for me team my name is David tomich
and if you enjoyed the video consider
subscribing for new weekly content